Hello Freak bitches rat scare the fuck out of me.
We've talked about on the podcast before,
I had a bad situation with a rat,
wants it,
a pool hall in New Jersey.
Me and my friend John went to this place to play pool and there's this fucking
huge rap.
I'll never forget this big giant fucking crazy yellow teeth and scare the shit
out of me getting bitten by the rat race.
I have a great rat story and I really wanted something good one.
Um,
so back,
back in the Disney?
No.
What'd you ask her?
She's not
oil.
It's pretty dark.
So like you know what,
let me,
let me paint this with my tone postcards.
Dark,
dark.
So I used to work in retail and the story,
yeah,
let's call it
rad spread.
That's actually really loud.
Sorry
blood.
So I was working in retail and it was a horrible job.
It was like totally degrading as a human and all you would do is fold clothes
all day and it was really expensive and these people would come in and spend
ridiculous amounts of money on clothes and they were just shitty and mean and
rude and rich,
whatever.
Not that that all constitutes,
but it was just an unpleasant experience.
And from whether it was a customer or the staff that,
you know,
my employers were just not kind and they didn't give a shit about you.
So I was already,
I knew I was kind of walking on thin ice because I wasn't like enthusiastic
about being there.
It was just a job.
And um,
one day before the biggest sale of the year where people like late ladies freak
out,
I came into the store and that weekend there had been like,
there had been indications and evidence that there were rodents because,
and I,
you know what?
I knew it were,
it were rats cause I could smell them.
I swear to God.
I was like,
I could smell it.
Literally when someone says I can smell a rat,
there's a musty smell to them.
You can fucking smell them.
Oh,
it's totally,
cause my first house in La,
I moved into off of a Craig's list ad had rats and I knew I,
I was like that smell light.
I know that smell.
That was from my old house.
That's a rat.
So long story short,
the exterminators come in and set traps the night before.
So Saturday morning when like this big sale starts,
every,
all the girls were like,
oh my God.
Do you think they call it something?
I Dunno.
We walk into the store and there's like,
there's one dead rat upstairs,
there's one in the traps downstairs,
another one downstairs.
And then there was another,
there was a trap that had been deployed and there was a piece of a big large
piece of a tail and blood.
I'm talking blood all over the clothes,
all over the wall,
but no rat.
And one of the girls had walked into the front of the,
of the store and also you should know there was a line forming outside of people
that wanted to get in to get this end of the year sale.
One of the girls walks in,
she goes,
oh with that,
and it was the size of a cat and it was the rat that got that got out of the
trap that like lost its tail was in the middle of the store bleeding and it was
like this big,
everybody's freaking out.
One of the girls was ballsy enough to throw a trash can over it.
So it's like,
no,
it's like screaming in this.
And so at this point and this point,
it's time.
It is time to,
to open the store and all that.
Like people are knocking on the window and we were able to,
like,
we were able to sort of create a diversion and put some clothes racks so you
couldn't see the trashcan
on the window.
Nobody was letting them know what I mean?
This was like a,
it was screaming like you couldn't no one [inaudible] so we called the
exterminator.
Oh it gets so much better.
The exterminator comes back.
We're like,
dude,
there's a fucking live rat in the store.
We can't open the doors.
We have a sale.
There's a line around the block,
like,
you know the owner,
everybody's on the phone,
everybody's freaking out,
exterminator shows up.
And he walks in,
he's like,
oh yeah,
that's a,
that's a problem.
And he's like,
well I don't know my pellet gun.
So,
and the next thing I know,
he walks out to his truck and he comes back with a two by four and he's like,
you ladies might want to step back,
kicks the trashcan open and just fucking splat.
Like he was
watching him,
watching him fucking blow up of watermelon in the middle of the store.
So then,
oh,
it gets so much better.
So after he kills the rat and it's like guts and end trails are all over the
place.
The Mat store managers like,
ladies,
we need to clean this up and opened the store.
I was like,
are you fucking serious?
So like buckets of bleach and whatever clothing has the blood on it.
Just take it out.
We'll,
we'll,
you know,
we'll cancel it out later.
So we're cleaning,
we're running around.
And I'm not kidding you,
the door's open five minutes.
And the manager who was my age,
calls me upstairs and she's like,
Suzanne,
can I have a word with you?
And I'm like,
yeah,
sure,
whatever.
Go upstairs and I get fucking fired.
She was like,
look,
you know,
we've been wanting to talk to you about,
your performance here.
And like,
I don't feel,
I know that you want to be a musician,
just want to be,
and I was like,
fuck it.
But anyway,
I was like,
you couldn't fire me before he made me clean up the rats blood.
I had to clean up the blood and then get fired.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Like it was one of those moments where I literally,
I lost my shit and then she was like,
well,
you can stay for the rest of the day if you want.
I was like,
you think I want to stay here and look at you.
I hate you.
You know,
it's horrible.
But it's such a good story.
So going through it was all worth it at the time.
Well,
it was just,
I'd never,
I had never experienced like any,
it's such a fantastical story.
Fantastic story.
It's crazy.
Isn't it funny how a story that is absolutely horrible at the time becomes
awesome?
Oh yeah.
It was really good in the past.
It was a low point though,
cause it was so insane.
Like when someone in like dig,
like just degrades you like that.
Like she said,
I know you're trying to be a musician,
but like your heart's on in it.
And I was like,
of course I don't want to go out and sell it again.
Yeah.
I don't want to cleaning up.
Right,
exactly.
You're right.
I just don't get rats or two by fours.
You need to examine your priorities.